hello the Internet am I in a hole I look
like I'm sure you're really sure than me
I'm always sure I'm Gavin dad we're the
slow mo guys I almost couldn't remember
the name of our channel for a second
there's this company called SOG or SOG
I'm not sure how they say it they were
like hey if we send you knives you want
to try and cut a bullet off with one and
I thought yeah yeah just reply yes yes
here's my dress yeah nobody use a real
bullet were just gonna use our trusty
air pistol because it's way less
dangerous and I have a very small
backyard we're discharging a firearm
would be insanity you've got a small
backboard here yeah I think a bullet
would probably go through that so we're
gonna try and cut the palate pop these
two balloons it reminds me one of those
22 plinks to videos yeah I'm gonna do it
solve over your shoulder like that I'm
not gonna be like here fall over I'm
just gonna be like right next to the
thing missing all the time we're gonna
use the 2511 on this one
need a fast camera need a high frame
rate let's see what happens shall we
will start off by shooting this at
28,000 frames a second in 720p and that
means the use of the V 25:11 which is
very loud okay what's your predictions
for this first shot it's gonna go as
it's the first shot I might need to get
my eye in pulling it in yeah remember
the candle video we did yeah took a few
goes didn't it did so I'm thinking this
is gonna be something similar where we
have to get but we have to get it
perfect on the left to right but doesn't
marry oh forget it lots of perfect on
the up and down so all right I'm getting
over that I'm gonna I'm gonna go you got
your eye protection on what I Pro yeah
I got hit yeah what with was he a shot I
don't know somebody you're right yeah I
know if it's balloon or not vodka it was
a pellet it's a tiny piece of pellet
what if it was this bouncing back it's
not very safe lovely split yeah not not
really a 50-50 split
but is it two pieces on that one slit so
split two three yeah see there it's hit
the yeah it's coming right back ass
how's that wait
it's come off it's made a little chip in
the wood and it's now just hurtling back
towards my hat that looked like he was
going almost into the lens good job it
didn't yeah I mean it hit my hand and it
didn't hurt that much
so it probably would have just dinged
the glass but still we need to rethink
our angles here maybe it's just as the
angle of the backstop perfectly hit it
and came back what the chances of that
lay down gonna go on anywhere damn good
job we were in eye protection I did say
you got your own protection
it went right over your head yeah no
balloon is like weak at the rim so I
have to like it's not like you know when
you blow into one normally it like holds
the rim and like you just blow into it
it's like weak so I'm like it's not let
me blow into it to avoid the same thing
happening again where it obviously hit
the wood there and bounced straight back
of the camera no try tilting the wood
back so that because of the angle it's
gonna go higher sounds good miss the
camera do you want like a whole face
protection B Yeah right
good idea I've changed the resolution to
512 by 320 which is teeny-weeny but we
are now at 120 thousand frames a second
and I've got a nice long tree cable so I
don't get hit again
huh think I missed think you may have
did you miss the knife no I think I hit
the side of the knife and it deflected
to the left and hit the balloon all
right no no oh you actually got it I did
get it perfect so think the thought was
just in the angle the actual shot on the
knife all right satisfying perfect where
did it go so went into the purple one
didn't pop it went straight through and
I think just missed the green one what
came out the other side of the purple
and ripping it huh it must have been
missed by such a fine amount on that
green there yeah very close all right
let's reset okay you know looking at the
footage it was it was like it was almost
touching it I feel like it looked like
it directly went into and just
disappeared
it must have it just slightly good is
that from it no maybe do you think they
could be from it from like a scrape that
could be you know see if we traced that
I can just about see the knife from this
position here so it must have just
screams it just goes past there
that's so close it's for some curiosity
here I've now switched the focus from
being on the front of the blade so it's
now the front of the balloons because
we've seen what happens when it splits
on the blades so now really just
interested in seeing what happens at
this point because on this balloon it
went in and then popped the other side
of the balloon like it didn't split from
the hole so weird
yeah happened even though it missed that
one what was cool to see about that one
is that you saw the pellet go through
the front carry on through the middle of
the balloon and it still had enough
speed and there was still enough tension
in the back of the balloon that it split
through the back too like so I didn't
just get caught up in the loose rubber
it was still going fast enough
and this was still stretched enough for
it to just go what see you later that
really puts into perspective how quickly
those those pellets go yeah cuz so by
the time it hit the back of the balloon
half the balloon was already open yeah
and it was pretty much just air on air
no the entry was that big and it's still
managed to split at the other side
that's ridiculous
it can race through a balloon quicker
than the balloon can pop fast it's fast
it was a bullet it'd be even faster
because I'm firing directly down the
blade it's incredibly difficult to
actually see where the middle is if not
impossible because so thin because it's
so thin so if you look directly in the
middle of the blade you see that only
one side should be purple and then this
side should be purple yeah yeah
so that's why I'm using two different
colors so that I can actually see the
middle of the blade basically like right
directly in between the yellow and the
purple because otherwise it'd just be
all purple I'd be like I don't know what
I mean
Oh amazing split again Oh simultaneous
no identical in both six image here as a
lovely shot thank you and well done for
your shop thank you Thank You Daniel
we will now get a side on angle with the
green and the yellow how about that what
surprised me for some reason no idea why
it surprised you
yeah sure sure no balloons bloody yeah
it was loud
[Music]
so I managed to after looking find half
of the pallet oh yeah I fired so it's
been completely split in half by the
knife as you can see the outside of it
is kind of dull and rusty because I let
it get wet and didn't really look after
it but if I turn it over it's completely
shiny and new
the internal motor and it's just been
perfectly sliced it's nice very slow
Schwing looking footage there
metal-on-metal satisfying how it just
perfectly sliced it in half yeah it's
not even managed to dent the knife it's
just sort of stained it I think the
pellets just really soft
yeah I'm sure if you hit the pellets
against anything they would mush and
split apart but because it's such a
sharp knife it's making very clean cuts
through it yeah leaving you with that
sort of polished edge on the inside it's
even making like the pellets not
perfectly straight but the inside it's
been cut is like sort of concave like
that because it's going like that around
the knife and then being sent either
direction so it's sort of going very
cool yeah hopefully you enjoyed that
video feel free to follow us on Twitter
we've got a channel it's this one we've
got a second channel as well it's that
one feel free to subscribe to both and
we will see you in the next video love
you got this one we got that word one of
these what are these just a sod for the
knife so it can't be SOG it's gonna be
like standard operating gear or
something hmm
either way choose for the knife yeah